par la fenêtre vicat pavlenko contemple
le ciel de zaporizhya c'est ici qu'elle
a trouvé refuge environ 300 km de
l'enfer de mario paul un chemin semé
d'embûches
il y avait du verre des fils électriques
à terre des voitures incendiées des
corps calcinés nous avons été arrêté au
poste de contrôle et nous avons entendu
des bombes a redonné un travail
comme vicat ces rescapés viennent
d'arriver à zaporijia dans ce
supermarché transformés en centres
d'accueil de nombreux déplacés ici ont
vu la mort de près à l'image de ces
femmes qui étaient abrités avec des
centaines de civils dans le théâtre de
mario paul lorsque celui ci a été
bombardée le 16 mars dernier plus de 300
personnes ont perdu la vie dans les
décombres
la panique à la destruction les débris
les blessés les morts les pleurs du sang
des gémissements de la poussière partout
pendant l'effondrement il y avait un
nuage blanc de poussière on ne voyait
rien c'était horrible bum comme le
encore plus de cent mille civils
seraient encore bloqués à marioupol sans
accès à l'eau ni à l'électricité
bombardé sans relâche cette cité
portuaire stratégique est au bord de la
catastrophe humanitaire
les autorités russes et ukrainiennes
s'accusent mutuellement d'empêcher la
mise en place de couloirs d'évacuation
d'après le président volodymyr zelensky
l'armée russe serait coupable de
bombardement sur les convois
humanitaires